كل صاروخ يتم إسقاطه ، نعم
يعني أن الحياة تم إنقاذها
هنا حيث تم
إسقاط صاروخ gephard الألماني قصير المدى أو هنا صاروخ واحد
بمدفع رشاش ،
إنه لأمر مؤسف أنني لم أسقط
ثلاثة ، إنه لأمر مخز أن اثنين مروا بهما
أصابوا أهدافًا مدنية أو حرجة
مرافق البنية التحتية والناس
يعملون هناك ،
هؤلاء هم صيادو الطائرات بدون طيار الأوكرانيون وفي
النهار والليل يقومون بمسح أعين السماء
في ظهور رؤوسهم
مدفعهم الرشاش المحمّل على عربة مدرعة
يتاجر بهشاشة الدفء ،
مسارات الصواريخ
والطائرات بدون طيار تتغير باستمرار مما
يعني أن  لم تكن الوحدات الثابتة
كافية ، لذلك أنشأنا وحدات متنقلة في معظم
الليالي ، هذا ما تبدو عليه السماء فوق
أوكرانيا وتبدو وكأنها
أكثر من عام من الحرب ، كل ما
تساعده معدات Western Equipment
ليلة الأربعاء أكثر من 90 صاروخًا
وثماني طائرات بدون طيار من طراز الشهيد تم اكتشافها من  تم
اعتراض أكثر من 30 صاروخًا وأربعة شهداء يقول
الجيش الأوكراني
هنا في بلدة الكوبيين على خط المواجهة ،
يمكنك أن ترى ما حدث منذ أكثر من عام من
نيران المدفعية الثقيلة وقذائف الهاون ، فقد
كان الحال مرة أخرى
ليلة الأربعاء ليس هناك الكثير من الهواء  يمكن أن
يفعل الدفاع حيال ذلك بشكل عام ، ما
يقوله الجيش الأوكراني هو أنه
بمساعدة الغرب ، كانت أنظمة دفاعه الجوي
فعالة بشكل ملحوظ ،
ومنذ بداية الغزو
إذا لم يحدث هذا ، فمن
المحتمل ألا نتحدث إليكم الآن  ولن
يكون هناك بلد مثل
أوكرانيا بفضل سلاح الجو ، لقد
تمكنا حقًا من الاحتفاظ بمفاتيح
السماء ، هذه نظرة عن قرب نادرة على
تكنولوجيا إيران للموت ، وهي طائرة
بدون طيار من شاهي سليمة نسبيًا لأنها تم اصطيادها
من الأسود  البحر في رأسه
كان سيحمل 50 كيلوجرامًا من
المتفجرات ، هذا ما يبدو عليه 20 كيلوجرامًا ، نعم هذا ما
يبدو على
الأرض
من حرب الاستنزاف الروسية المدمرة
مع سقوط ضحايا مدنيين في
معظم الليالي.
إليزابيث الشرقية